but first the military's woke makeover
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now if you were chairman of the joint
chiefs of state of staff and
secretary of defense or any top military
leader today
there's a lot that should keep you up at
night right
put yourself in that role but think
about it most all of it is coming from
china
threats to our ally taiwan our strategic
ally in the pacific
china's itching to invade them threats
from china's hackers and intel agencies
their growing presence in africa plus
china is threatening us in space but our
current chairman of the joint chiefs
general mark milley is apparently
spending a lot of his waking hours
worrying about
what he thinks is wrong with the united
states
now yesterday when republican
congressmen raised reasonable questions
about
whether it's a good idea to expose our
soldiers to anti-american propaganda in
the form of this critical race theory
stuff
he just ended up lashing out sounding
more like a commentator on
msnbc than a military leader
so what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that
so it is important that the leaders now
and in the future
do understand it i've read miles seitang
i've read
i've read karl marx i've read lenin that
doesn't make me a communist
so what is wrong with understanding
having some situational understanding
about the country for which we are here
to defend
well the general apparently failed to
think through the logic
and ramifications of his stated position
now in the first place critical race
theory is
based on a lie the lie that america is
marred by racism
in every aspect of society and therefore
our entire system must be upended and
then remade
ibram kennedy's anti-racism guide is
the best known of these marxist
anti-american screeds
so why is it on the military's
recommended reading list
tom cotton pulled back the curtain
earlier this week
the notion that capitalism is
essentially racist and racism is
essentially
capitalist that the only remedy for past
discrimination
is present discrimination admiral gilda
how did these books go on your reading
list
sir i chose a variety of books or over
50 books on my reading list
to give our sailors a wide range of
information from which i hope they can
make fast
facts-based decisions on uh both their
ability to look
outwardly at uh potential aggressors
like china and russia
as well as looking inwardly and being
honest with ourselves
in areas that we need to improve
think about that the troops are hearing
that in order to be honest with
themselves
about how they need to improve they then
need to read a book by a guy who thinks
america is inherently wicked and evil
does that make any sense the message to
the troops is this
put your lives at risk for the usa but
remember
the usa is a systemically racist
structurally biased country
and by the way you and your parents live
on stolen land
look what top military leaders have on
their nightstands what they choose to
read that's up to them
but how is it appropriate or helpful to
our young military personnel
just starting out to force this on them
how does it promote unit cohesion
the first thing we should be teaching
our soldiers our airmen
all of them is that we're a good and
noble country that is
worthy of their amazing sacrifice
critical race theory sends the opposite
message
and as for general milly's attempt to
justify the unjustifiable by
noting that he's personally read the
work so some of the worst civilian
villains of our time big deal
obviously we're not going to expose our
troops to every possible twisted theory
out there
what's the point of that they're trained
to be warriors in many roles
and they are among the finest in the
world
reading abram candy will no more help
our troops
understand the united states than fidel
castro's writings would have in the
1960s
the reason that the military gave in to
the critical race theory craze
is simple because the biden
administration
is determined to use race as a political
weapon
and the biden administration is
enlisting the military
to help them of course they try to deny
this and
claim that anyone who attacks critical
race theory in the military is attacking
the troops
oh please another logical fallacy
the non-commissioned officers the
enlisted men and women
they signed up to be in the u.s military
not for a never-ending racism seminar
it wasn't long ago that biden made this
promise to our men and women in uniform
your incredible heroes and incredible
patriots
i will never ever dishonest dishonor you
i will never disrespect you
i will never politicize the work you do
that goes for our civilian professionals
as well as a career military
of course that didn't last long less
than a month later the pentagon
announced the so-called domestic
extremists
issue that they were the most serious
threat
in existence to the us military which we
all know is code for purging
the ranks of conservatives so as china
continues to build and grow its global
influence
uh the pentagon chief lloyd austin chose
to
focus on white supremacists
as a major problem now this is straight
out of the critical rear
critical theory playbook but the not
denials they came anyway
we don't we don't embrace uh critical
race theory
and i think i think that's a spurious uh
uh
conversation and so we are focused on
extremist behaviors and and not uh not
ideology not not not people's thoughts
not people's
uh political orientation behaviors is
what we're focused on
well that's just not true the military
is launching an effort
to monitor social media activity of the
troops meaning
their personal political views and other
views will be examined
for so-called extremism even if they do
nothing illegal
to act on those viewpoints the fact is
too many in top leadership have
forgotten the proper role of the us
military
they answer to civilian leadership not
the other way around
remember when trump wanted to pull our
troops out of afghanistan
well the top brass in the military they
fought him every step of the way
there was always a reason not to bring
the troops home
and now when you watch what's going on
they're even resisting biden
pushing the narrative of course that
when we pull out it'll be another saigon
they did the same in iraq by the way
despite public opinion and despite
stated administration policy
civilian control of the military is a
cornerstone of our entire system
if military leaders are perceived to be
parroting partisan
again msnbc style talking points
they're going to do to the armed forces
what tony fauci has done to public
health agencies
they'll hurt their standing and their
credibility with the american people
so republicans need to take all of this
very seriously
some already are like tom cotton and
josh hawley
the fact is post-afghanistan we need a
plan
to make our military more functional and
less political
beyond reasserting civilian control of
the armed forces
we have to eliminate all unnecessary
spending
cut everything from needless weapons
systems to pointless deployments
to the hiring of any racial or gender
identity consultants
our troops aren't served by bloated
budgets
only the bureaucracy and the defense
industry benefit from that
thirdly our focus should be almost
entirely on china
staying ahead of the ccp and blunting
their influence wherever we can
and it's not going to be easy in fact
it will be the great challenge of this
century
but we must take it more seriously
fourth we need new leadership
anyone who seeks to purge patriotic
volunteers from our military
based on changing political whims and
anyone who spends more time thinking
about january 6
than china shouldn't be leading our
troops
we need more victories against our
adversaries abroad
and less animosity toward our own people
at home
our troops should be encouraged to have
faith in our system
after all they're the ones who volunteer
to protect and defend it
why should they or anyone commit to
defending
a way of life that their reading is
inherently racist who'll sign up for
that job
perhaps that's a question that general
milley should spend some time thinking
about
before his next appearance on capitol
hill
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else